on the outskirts of cambridge scientists
are tracking the spread of the new
variant of the virus
10 000 samples a week taken from people
having coveted tests
are analyzed by the welcome sanger
institute
they've spotted mutations that not only
make the virus more transmissible
but also it's now been revealed more
deadly
if you took somebody in their 60s a man
in their 60s
the average risk is that for a thousand
people
who got infected roughly 10
would be expected to unfortunately die
with the virus with the new variant for
a thousand people
infected roughly 13 or 14 people
might be expected to die genetic
analysis of virus samples has also shown
that the south african variant has now
been detected in at least 44 people in
the uk
research suggests it may evade some
antibodies
and with another version in brazil
significant mutations that give the
virus an
edge seem to be cropping up faster
scientists say that's because there's
lots of cases
in general we think that it's just
simply that there's just so much virus
around
and so many different people that the
the probability of one of these
mutations occurring
is increased by the fact we've got lots
of virus so really the
the real answer for this is getting the
number of cases down
since the virus started spreading in
wuhan it's been mutating every two weeks
into distinct but related versions
visualized as an increasingly crowded
family tree
by the next strain tracker most
mutations don't matter
only recently have new more significant
descendants
evolved in the uk south africa and
brazil
some of the significant mutations
cropping up in the new variants of the
virus here in the uk
in south africa and brazil are the same
scientists call it convergent evolution
just as birds and bats have both evolved
wings independently
to fly so the virus is coming out with
the same strategy
for evading the immune system new
research in cambridge shows how fast the
virus can evolve
inside the bodies of people with poorly
functioning immune systems
a man treated for 100 days became an
incubator
with a virus changing in response to
every treatment
within days you would see shifts big big
population shifts and it tells you that
there's so much virus turnover in
individuals as i've been saying
that this virus is replicating at huge
rates the really big changes in the
virus came when
he was given convalescent plasma and so
contains many different types of
antibodies
every time an infusion was given the
virus population completely changed
all the evidence shows the vaccines are
effective against the uk
variant five and a half million people
have so far had their first dose
and because the vaccines are being
targeted at those most at risk
deaths should soon start to fall despite
the new variant
thomas more sky news